we've just celebrated the first hundred
days of the russian invasion of ukraine
it was first announced more than three
months ago
nothing happens
and nothing will happen russia has no
plans of attacking ukraine we have no
reason to do that there is no military
infrastructure to do that
whatever we hear about the russian plans
is something we hear from the u.s
administration from the western media
and so for us it's very hard to to react
to all this rhetoric which is just a you
know a continuation of endless fakes
about russian's intentions
ukraine is a friendly nation
many many russians have relatives and
friends there
both my grandmothers are ukrainian so
you know
we are not going to attack our friendly
nation period
well you say there's no military
infrastructure to do that and yet we are
witnessing are we not the biggest
military buildup since the end of the
cold war a hundred battle groups in
place 14 more on the way reports of 60
attack and transport helicopters
arriving in crimea the deployment as you
know of many naval vessels uh in the
black sea including phibious assault
vessels we've got combat enablers there
including huge amounts of fuel we've
seen arriving enormous military
hospitals arriving bridge assets too how
can you possibly stand there and say
that there is no military infrastructure
when when ukraine is surrounded on three
sides
the pictures you are showing now
are pictures of standard military
installations which are many many
hundred miles away from ukrainian border
if there are any movements of the
russian forces
these are the movements related to
military exercises which we are doing on
our own soil
actually i was listening to mr
staltenberg and i was amazed by many
things but mostly by two things
first he said that russia should
de-escalate on its own territory which
to me sounds amazing too
is saying that nato is increasing its
military potential
in eastern europe but according to
russia nato founding act which he
actually also referred to nato is not
supposed to have any nukes and no troops
and no military infrastructure on the
new member states and that's actually
the point of russian peace proposals
we actually asked nato to get back to
nato russia founding act of 1997
where the rules of the
of the game were
well established they didn't do it
uh and they just rejected this proposal
as something unthinkable they rejected
something unthinkable the possibility
for non-expansion of nato
which was promised to the soviet union
back in 1990 1991 by every single
western leader who was visiting
moscow or with whom were russian leaders
soviet leaders were talking outside of
the country
i worked in the crown and then i met
douglas hurd i met james baker
they told exactly that i don't think in
30 years the principles of nato somehow
changed dramatically
and again
all this talk about autocracy democracy
can you name me
just one dimension of democracy in which
for example more democratic than russia
freedom of the speech
political pluralism
minority rights
racial equality
just name one
well it's very interesting you go down
that route obviously international
observers would love to come and watch
russian elections in full i'm sure i
want to go back to your idea that this
is exercises people have been monitoring
treat movements from the pacific coast
why do you need to move troops from the
pacific coast for exercises why has
leave been cancelled in russia why do
why do people track the trains that are
bringing field hospitals and tanks into
belarus and other parts of the ukrainian
border
why why do you need 130 000 although i
have to say the ukrainians estimate now
147
000 troops to carry out exercises why is
it necessary to carry out anything on
this scale and i go back to my first
question what is president putin's
intentions
well first of all
all the figures you name uh are figures
from the western media
governments and so on i don't have this
and of course there can you give me the
figures then you tell me the figures
yeah i'm not sure the figures of those
who are talking about in exercise
may i
okay
yes you may speak sorry apologies
to you carry on
the amount of forces which are
participating in the exercise village
thirty thousand it's quite a standard
military exercise
we're a huge country russia is not just
a european country it's europe pacific
country
we have 11 time zones
and we uh when we exercise in the east
we bring forces from the european part
of russia when they exercise in the west
to bring forces
from east
there is no intention in russia to
attack ukraine
what president putin wants actually
we proposed two drafts one the draft of
the security agreement with the united
states another is the draft of security
agreement with nato
we've got the answers which do not
address the security concerns of russia
as for the military exercises russia can
conduct it
on the soil
wherever and whenever it wants
it's no
threat to anybody
we are actually concerned with nato
infrastructure
approaching our border nato is the
biggest military alliance on earth it
accounts for 75 percent of global
military expenditures
russia's military budget is seven
percent of that of nato and this huge
military machine is approaching russian
border for 30 years
with against all our objections and
that's something that really worries us
it's not about ukraine choosing choosing
its alliance it's about fighting
alliance approaching our borders
and this alliance is not for defense we
know it was fighting in afghanistan and
fighting in iraq it was fighting in
syria it was fighting in libya it was
fighting in yugoslavia after the end of
the cold war and
okay they killed millions of people so
for us this is a challenge
as for the possibility i understand
you're using those examples
to show the russian view that nato is an
offensive organization when you know
full well it was set up as a defensive
organization can i put it to you also
one idea which is obviously muted in the
west that actually president putin is
one of those people that will never get
over the fall of the ussr and the loss
of the 15 soviet republics that went
independent and in fact doesn't really
understand why ukraine would want to be
a democracy and an independent one at
that and actually sees ukrainians as
sort of confused russians and poles and
maybe uh you know that they're not
really a nation it's not really a nation
and is is that something that would
occur to him he's written hasn't he
about you know marry me um and so on so
so what does does he fully accept that
ukraine is an independent democratic
nation and that is fine by him
well i do accept ukraine as an
independent nation for sure russia
provided ukraine independence as other
14 former soviet republics it was done
by russia
as for democracy of course this is
questionable i don't think ukraine is a
democracy otherwise all the critics of
the regime would not be in jail dead or
in exile
and they would not close all the
opposition tv channels uh news media and
so on and so forth i don't think ukraine
is democracy ukraine is run by the
united states of america
until they left kiev there were 3 000
american americans with diplomatic bus
passports in kiev running the country
you know uh
being becoming part of the alliance this
is the policy of those who run ukraine
you know we didn't have problems with
the previous governments of ukraine
which were independent really
from the western domination
this government is not free to reflect
the will of their own people so i don't
think ukraine is a democracy
i think russia actually is more
democratic than ukraine we have some
problems with democracy but not as huge
as in ukraine so this whole idea of the
west presenting some principle of values
is not really well received in russia
because we know also the history
of the western values
nationalism chauvinism
fascism
nazism
racial discrimination
global slave trade this was not invented
by
russians or the chinese these were all
the western values for centuries
actually
for us the west is not the fourth of the
good enough we experienced the number of
history many many centuries of attacks
from the west
they were attacked by the crusaders they
were attacked yeah
to our borders with a huge military
machine which was not made yeah i just
love nikon i'm apologizing i have to
interrupt you because the british prime
minister has been speaking after a cobra
meeting i apologize for cutting you off
there fascinating to talk to you and
hear the russian viewpoint first deputy
chairman of the state duma committee on
international affairs we much appreciate
your time thank you